bonsoir à tous je suis très très content
d'être parmi vous ce soir pour parler de
choses qui nous concerne tous de votre
visage de vos émotions dont le préparant
cet exposé il y avait à un article qui
vient de sortir dans le magazine forbes
qui qui cite les grandes j'irai tendance
au niveau technologique qui vont quelque
part changer le monde et parmi ces
grands tendance
on parle de la montée en puissance de
l'intelligence artificielle
donc cette capacité-là de doter des
machines d'intelligence et ceci pour
deux raisons principales la première on
a de plus en plus en fait de machines
qui sont de plus en plus rapide
et puis la deuxième raison c'est on a de
plus en plus de donner de grosses bases
de données qui nous permet de faire ce
qu'on a fait de l'apprentissage
donc cette puissance de calcul et s'est
donné aujourd'hui permettent alors de
nos ordinateurs de faire des choses
assez intéressante ils peuvent la mettre
aux ordinateurs de voir par exemple
aujourd'hui vous avez des systèmes de
reconnaissance de visages qui marche
très très bien on l'utilisons ce qu'on
appelle dating d'apprentissage vous avez
des ordinateurs qui sont capables d vous
écouter vous parler et voir jauger vos
émotions allez comprendre
donc c'est sûr sur des les termes en
fait que je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
cela comment aujourd'hui des ordinateurs
sont capables ou pour être capable de de
comprendre vous vos émotions
alors pourquoi les émotions intéresse
tout le monde parce que les émotions
font partie de notre quotidien
les émotions donc va pas avait pas mis
enfin d'interaction humaine sociale
c'est que vous très important les
émotions ont un rôle très important sur
notre santé et notre bien être
et puis parfois ils guident même
nous nos achats je dirais presque faites
attention parce que certains même
voudrait les utiliser pour vous inciter
à acheter
donc faites attention à ça et puis enfin
dans nos prévisions les émotions jouent
un rôle très très importante pour toutes
ces raisons là en fait les émotions sont
quelque chose d'important à comprendre
mais à côté de ça qu'est ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui on est de plus en plus
connectés nous avons des machines à part
des ordinateurs des smartphones
connectés à ces machines
mais ces machines sont de plus en plus
très très intelligente et très puissante
mais n'ont pas cette capacité là de
d'interagir avec nous de manière un peu
plus tirer human est une façon de leur
ont dit mal s'il est d'injecter un peu
plus d'émotion donc l'objectif c'est
justement peut-être demain vous aurez
peut-être une voiture et je crois que je
suis sûr et certain dans 2 3 ans vous
allez avoir des voitures équipées de
petites caméras qui vont analyser votre
visage à partir de cette analyse là ils
vont comprendre peut-être vous êtes dans
un état stressé et déclenchait peut-être
une musique un peu plus douce et voir
vous proposer des services
c'est va être dans nos maisons est de
plus en plus connectés peut-être demain
vous allez avoir dans votre
réfrigérateur qui va être de plus en
plus connecté une petite caméra qui
avait analysé votre état émotionnel et
vous suggérez peut-être ddd menus en
fonction de votre état à l'instant t
et voilà donc ça c'est ce qui est en
train de se préparer mais l'étude des
émotions ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
elle date de déjà de charles darwin qui
a essayé de comprendre un peu comment à
travers notre visage et notre corps on
arrive quelque part a envoyé des
émotions aux autres il s'est intéressé à
ça non seulement pour pour nous enfin
les êtres humains mais aussi même pour
les animaux
donc ça date de très très très loin et
alors ce que je vais raconter s'est
passé c'est vrai que quand on m'a invité
ici à tedx je suis toujours en fait
intéressé de parler de ce que je fais au
niveau recherche
et quand on m'a dit c'est à douai donc
je me suis dis patate à lille lille
douai 1 samedi soir
enfin alors que je prenne ma voiture etc
mais réfléchissons et en travaillant sur
cet exposé ils ont fait le vraiment un
très bon choix d'organiser c'était dixie
ca do et parce que vous allez voir
l'étude des analyses explose les
expressions faciales est né presque ici
à 12 c du chef du chêne le grand
neurologue français qui est né à boulons
sur bert et qui a fait ses études
scolaires ici à adu et qui est parti a
pris après à paris pour fêter les études
de médecine après il est retourné chez
lui à boulogne-sur-mer et du chêne ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a essayé de faire quand
vous voyez à votre gauche
il a essayé de comprendre on stimule un
certain nombre de muscles seul visage
qu'est ce qui se passe en termes
d'expression et s'est rendu compte
l'observation c'est que ont stimulé des
muscles dans le mal est précis sur
visage ils arrivèrent génère à centre
d'expressions faciales
par exemple la joie donc il faisait ça
je rassemble deux passions donc je vous
recommande pas de faire ça chez vous
avec les lectrices it et c'est quoi
c'est dangereux
voilà donc ça vous allez voir ces
travaux du chef anne impact
impressionnant sur ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui alors plus tard plus taillé
d'autres travaux et c'est vraiment des
travaux assez important qui ont un
impact sur le
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui une nouvelle
analyse des héros sur l'expression c'est
paul ekman paul ekman qui qui a aussi
travaillé sur les travaux du chêne c'est
ça c'est intéressant mais paul est que
mal il s'intéressait à comprendre
certaine universalité nos expressions
faciales dans ce qu'il a fait donc c'est
un groupe civils américains ce qui la
fait les parties à la papouasie nouvelle
guinée
on expose une expédition dans une tribu
qui n'avait jamais vu en fait de culture
gérer étrangères extérieures et là
regardez c'est ces personnes comment ils
arrivent en fait à partir d'une photo de
personnes qui étaient plutôt en occident
et ce qu'ils arrivent à comprendre leurs
expressions faciales la joue assez
et si on du compte finalement que ces
personnes arrivées bien comprendre en
fait toutes façons de notre notre joie
notre tristesse et donc est ce qu'il a
fait il a établi à partir de douala et
l'a établi une théorie en disant qu' il
ya star ou d'expressions faciales qui
sont universels qui sont qu'on va
retrouver plus tard au niveau de notre
analyse de deux visages qui sont on va
trouver la joie la tristesse la colère
le dégoût et la peur donc on a six qui
sont fondamentales et le reste quelque
part son de combinaison de ces six
expression de bath et donc à partir de
ce moment là le travail de chercheurs
comme en ce qui me concerne sur la plan
vision par ordinateur était de voir
qu'il était possible de 2,2 de proposer
des algorithmes au des programmes
informatiques capables à partir d'une
vidéo où une image de dire cette
expression ce visage là il correspond à
telle ou telle expression faciale
donc c'est tout un travail et la
difficulté est que lorsque une caméra au
regard de votre visage elle voit des
chiffres et vois pas autre chose nous
vois que des chiffres
donc tout le travail derrière ces deux
qu'est ce qu'on peut comprendre à partir
de ces chiffres là avec une difficulté
c'est que si vous me demandez de vous
écrire un port un pour une personne qui
est devant une caméra pour analyser son
visage je peux le faire je peux le faire
parce que simplement il faut analyser le
la morphologie du visage on peut faire
des choses assez intéressantes pour une
seule personne mais je vous demande
d'écrire
et de proposer un programme informatique
pour des millions de personnes les
choses chance parce qu'on a une
morphologie différente on a parfois des
expressions un peu différent différentes
et herat et donc il faut penser
autrement on peut pas écrire un
programme informatique comme ça à penser
autrement c'est quoi c'est le fait de
revenir mon point de départ mon point de
départ c'était que aujourd'hui on a une
puissance de calcul on a de la data la
donne est donc c'est ce qu'on va faire
ici c'est ce qu'on va faire ici avec
toutes les difficultés qu'on va
rencontrer c'est que une personne comme
ici vous voyez c'est la princesse k est
ici il est dans différentes positions
différentes grimaces et on a même des
cas extra ici à droite avec des grands
vins sont encore plus exagérer donc il
faut tenir compte en fait ce qu'on
appelle toutes ces variabilité de
données donc ce qu'on va faire on va
construire ce qu'on appelle des des
benchmark en fait des benchmarks et des
grosses bases de données et on va
collecter beaucoup de data beaucoup de
données qui correspond à toutes ces
expressions faciales et on va essayer
d'apprendre
on va apprendre à partir de ça c'est
exactement ce qu'ont fait lorsqu'on
apprend à un enfant on va lui présenter
un visage
on va lui dire ça correspond à la colère
ce visage là correspond à la surprise et
c'est donc on va essayer d'apprendre ses
différentes expressions faciales et pour
ça on a besoin de la donner on voit
aujourd'hui la donne et on peut la
contrôler on peut faire des choses
nous-mêmes reconstruire ce tube pas se
donner ou bien tout simplement parfois
on va directement sur youtube
on a des milliards de données à notre
disposition avec ce type d'expression
donc on va apprendre on va apprendre en
utilisant des techniques d'apprentissage
je voudrais un exemple ici de revenir à
ce que vous trouvez dans tout système de
reconnaissance des expressions faciales
tout d'abord les données on peut avoir
un petit traitement pour traiter ces
données là mais la partie le noyau le
plus important à la partie la plus
importante fondamentale cette partie là
donc une machine qui va apprendre on va
les présenter de données on va lui dire
tiens c'est un sourire tiens c'est de la
colère
et puis ça va on va faire tourner ces
machines là pendant plusieurs jours
voire deux jours une fois terminée on a
un système qui est capable de
reconnaître en fait nos expressions
faciales l'expression vassal du visage
avec toutes les différentes variabilité
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
alors je voudrais un exemple en fait de
se confesser faire aujourd'hui
donc là j'ai une petite vidéo à vous
montrer donc là c'est un exemple de ce
qu'on sait faire aujourd'hui on a ici un
système que nous avons développés nous
mêmes qui qui a appris en fait toutes
ces expressions faciales et la personne
qui est en face de la caméra maintenant
c'est vraiment un système en temps réel
ce que vous voyez c'est du taux réels
c'est à dire que vous êtes devant la
caméra et ça ça marche donc la personne
il va faire sa langue d'expression et le
système il va reconnaître qu'elle est là
l'expression qui correspond à cette
personne là vous voyez ici au niveau du
chama ici sur le visage le système et
ils détectent d'autres types
d'expressions faciales mais est toujours
une qui est dominante au niveau du
visage
alors ça c'est c'est moins d'étudiants
zappé un espace homme qui a développé ce
système là là il fait semblant en fait
ils jamais en colère c'est toujours
c'est quelqu'un qui est toujours content
comme ce que vous voyez ici donc la voie
là et ensuite ce qui va essayer de
montrer aussi et ça c'est ce qu'il est
en train de montrer c'est que le système
est très robuste
lorsque la personne bouge sa tête et
c'est ça c'est très important dans ce
type du système d'avoir ce type de son
appel de robustesse au mouvement de la
tête
et ensuite là ils exagèrent un peu il
joue l'acteur l'aï vraiment il le fait
bien
alors ensuite la niveau de la
démonstration ce qu'on vous montre aussi
aussi c'est ça aussi c'est important
parce que demain c'est subtil du système
il peut être installé sur un smartphone
ou une tablette donc il pourra des
conditions de lumière qui change donc on
a besoin de systèmes capables de tenir
compte en fait ce différents changements
donc là le système
il s'adapte il est capable de vous voyez
là ont même enlevé ses lunettes et le
système il est capable toujours de
reconnaître à l'expression de de cette
personne
voilà donc la ballon donc ça c'est un
alors ce type de système
vous l'aurez bientôt en fait sur vos
smartphones ou tablettes c'est des
choses en fait aujourd'hui dont domaine
du du possible peut-être même des vélos
des voitures ce qui nous intéresse aussi
et de manière indirecte beaucoup de ces
travaux là en fait honte à l'impact
haussier dans le domaine médical et
s'assure nous ça on tient beaucoup à ça
on a pas mal de travaux dans le domaine
de la médecine ou un exemple c'est de ce
qu'on appelle la douleur aujourd'hui
c'est à quelque chose de très important
vous voit analyser la douleur par
malheureusement pour certaines personnes
le seul moyen d'exprimer leur douleur
c'est à travers leurs visages et donc
les médecins ont besoin d'un salaire
voire des caméras pour analyser
l'expression de la personne est détecté
le moment de la douleur voire en fait
pouvoir mesurer l'intensité de la
douleur
et puis enfin je veux parler en fait à
travailler qui m'a qui m'a vraiment
touché et puis j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps au ch a ici à l'île australe avec
les experts en chirurgie du visage ici
on avait des personnes suite par exemple
d'un avc et surtout avec une paralysie
faciale et leur demander de simplement
de faire un petit sourire ça devient
vraiment quelque chose de dur et donc
les médecins à ce niveau là l'objectif
c'est de 2
son appel à ses maîtresses et le visage
parce que il est important de que la
personne puisse la retrouver en fait son
sourire presque d'origine donc ils vont
faire de l'injection ou bien de son
appel à de la chirurgie et à ce niveau
là notre rôle en tant que chercheur en
informatique c'est de mettre à la
disposition de ses médecins là des
outils qui vont leur permettre d'évaluer
de mesurer ce qu'on appelle la symétrie
du visage avant l'opération et après
l'opération donc on a demandé aux
patients de venir pendant avant
l'opération et on les as canet alors on
était encore partie très très loin parce
qu'on a ce cas elles mêmes leurs visages
en 3d donc leur sourire tu étais en 3d
et donc on a mesuré ce qu'on appelle la
sémitour leur visage avant l'opération
et puis ensuite on a refait la même
chose on leur a demandé de venir au ch
enfin ici au service pour analyser leur
visage et on a un autre disposition des
outils maintenant qui permettent de
mesurer ce type de son appel de symétrie
du visage avant et après l'opération
voilà quelques quelques idées en fait ce
qu'aujourd'hui ce que ce qu'on peut
faire avec
avec nos visages et puis je terminerai
en disant la chose suivante en préparant
cet exposé sur les émotions etc
je me rends compte que au fait il ya
sentant peut-être on était en train de
de robotiser en fait l'être humain avec
tout ce qui est ce qui est le de ski et
mécanisation de des tâches et puis
maintenant on se rend compte qu'il faut
humaniser en fait les machines voilà
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]